good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
monday unfortunately hate to be the one
to tell you guys it's monday hey claudia
how are you darn
you know what you did just ruined my day
i didn't even realize that it was monday
but you know what second monday in 2022
let's keep up our positive attitudes
we've got a new sickening webcam from
jackie yes my video on friday was
extremely unfortunate uh for a number of
reasons first of all i have a macbook
air which is so crazy because i do so
much on my computer you don't know how
many podcasts i record on my computer
how many videos are on like files that
are massive and this computer is a
really good computer but it's just not
meant for a podcasting queen so as you
guys know i've been struggling to order
a new computer i've ordered one but it's
going to be a few weeks because that's
just how things go these days
in the meantime though i thought my
video on friday was just unacceptable
the sun was coming in which also made it
like foggy but it's clear that my
computer camera is inferior to yours
so
i went out there and i got a webcam and
i'm loving it
it's something funny about the word
webcam like what is this 1997. it's
hysterical and i am a cam girl and you
know what i'm loving every minute of it
it's so it was an investment in your
future like not only can you produce a
more high-tech high quality podcast you
can also do like masturbation videos
pictures of your feet like you could do
all these different new avenues for
revenue and i just think that's what
like a business should be i completely
agree i'm loving the cam life and it's
given me just like this new lease so now
i do think our videos are
both very strong and now it's just like
clear like i'm fugly and my makeup is
trash and like you look really nice
oh my god you know thank you so much for
saying that that's really really sweet i
too have upgraded a little bit i got a
new ring light i got brand new
headphones i'm just trying to make the
most of our podcasting from home and i
think we're [ __ ] killing it honestly
no i'm really enjoying like every day
it's a new technological advancement if
you saw my desk i was just saying to
claudia like there are so many things
plugged in it's like i don't use my
computer microphone i use my external i
use my webcam i use my headphones it all
is propped up like on a puzzle and a
book it's very rube goldberg one thing
collapses and the whole show is taken
down
mine is propped up on my dyson air app
which is actually an amazing amazing um
it's not a great blow dryer in my
opinion but it's a great elevator for
your computer so that we're at eye level
with the camera i'm not getting like a
double chin moment from below yeah but
also these microphones would cancel out
a double chin also
that's really why i love podcasting from
home i very strategically place my
microphone over my chin
and it's just it's face tune you really
can't pay for yeah no the podcasting
from home life has just be really
you know
evolved leaps and bounds from where it
was and i'm feeling really good about it
i think everyone's enjoying it and it's
a great
you know solution for what's going on
right now and i'm just glad that we can
have video and have audio because i was
i actually listened to so many podcasts
this weekend but i only watch them i
will i'm one of those i'm a youtuber who
boycotts the show when it's not
video so like it needs i if you know i
need to talk the talk walk the walk and
i'm glad that we have video as well
otherwise if it were me i wouldn't be
watching i agree i love a video podcast
there's just nothing like seeing and
hearing no like when i see that someone
is going on someone else's podcast and
it looks like they have like an
interesting combo the only chance i have
of
watching is if it's video
yes especially when it's like
influencers because i just love to see
what people look like in real life a
hundred percent just the way people talk
the way their face moves it's all so
interesting i couldn't agree more but i
also think we can some people try to
intentionally not show us what they look
like worse i mean if i had it my way i
would and if i was like really smart i
would invent like a youtube that like
films you in facetune and you can
facetune your body and your skin but we
can't hide from the podcast
no no we can hide on the podcast we
can't hide from
from the video but you know that's what
i meant sorry sorry yeah especially like
the in studio video like what you look
like is what you look like
yeah um how was your weekend my weekend
was good i mean it was really crazy
because once brew and i did those
shrooms like everything just went off
the rails fell into place so it was good
i mean i was home i watched a lot of tv
and
i think that's really all i did um
i didn't read that much i started a new
book last night that so far is so good
our friend kristen's husband pete
recommended it and the last book he
recommended to me was my number one book
of 2021 portrait of a mirror so remember
i will take a recommendation from him
anytime
but
yeah i watch oh i watched 1883.
okay so good it's like a movie every
episode is a movie and it's all about
like the journey out west which i really
don't know a lot about so i was just so
enjoying
and then i watched victoria i'm watching
it again i'm on season two you need to
watch i know it's on my list of things
but i was very busy this weekend
watching the hype house netflix show so
that i could talk about it here and i
have so many thoughts
overall positive or
negative when i was watching it i was
like the show's amazing but it went on
too long for a show that's like actually
about nothing and in the grand scheme of
things like i know a lot about the tick
tockers they didn't get like the good
ones you know but they got
hootie little
honey little hootie and he was kind of
like the um the center of the show
because he left hype house during
filming so it was all about him he's
like very much decided to be a musician
and not a social media star and there
was a lot of takeaways from the show um
one of the takeaways was that like i
love nikita dragon i didn't really know
who she was like i knew her journey i
knew she was like one of the first
people to go through um
gender transition on youtube and that
like made her an icon but what i've
known about her in recent years is just
like her scandals and just getting to
like see her on a personal level she's
so funny i feel like if i hung out with
her i would just love her um i think the
show actually did great things for
certain of certain cast mates like i
think nikita's popularity has to have
gone up and some of the other characters
like alex and thomas
are just not um coming off well on the
show and i think they know that they've
been making tick tocks about how like
netflix like produced them out like so
bad well i would say that like anyone
who came up on youtube
even five years ago like
so much of that is about personality so
so many of those influencers have like
banging personalities because you have
to be entertaining and keep up the
conversation
for
long long periods of time now with tick
tock like that's not what it's about so
it makes complete sense to me that
someone who you know
came up before tick tock has more of a
robust personality than someone who got
famous for 15 second videos
yeah and so nikita was the only one on
the show who's like um not a tick tocker
at heart you know she's a real social
media personality
all the other ones were um kids who came
up on tick tock and they're all living
in this house and they're like fighting
about money and they all come from kind
of like you know um difficult childhoods
and they're all struggling with their
mental health and honestly i just didn't
feel like them all living in this house
together was the best thing for them and
you could just see their mental health
deteriorating and they're just like
fighting about this dumb [ __ ] and this
guy thomas who started the hype house
like really feels he's so
bitter because he was like we launched
charlie dixie and addison and it's like
well actually i could argue that charlie
dixie and addison launched you like the
high pass was only interesting because
of a couple of girls like avani and
they've all left the high pass they were
never even a part when you hear them
talk about it like they were never even
a part of it they all like hung out and
did a photo shoot in la once and that
like launched the hype house but they
were never officially a part of it they
never lived in the house so
it was really really interesting i just
wish that they had gotten the hype house
like today like doesn't really exist in
the way that it used to so they got the
high pass tv show like a year too late
do they live is the physical house the
same house as the one
from back in the day
no so the way that i perceived it was
that they moved and this is why little
hoodie didn't want to move in they
recently moved into like an enormous
house in moorpark which i believe is
about an hour outside of la and is
clearly much cheaper because they're not
making as much money as they used to
as a as a house i think individually
they're all doing really well um and so
little hootie who's like wanting to work
he just got down to a record label he
doesn't want to move to this house
that's an hour away he wants to be in la
be able to work you know go to sessions
or whatever so the hype house offered to
pay for his house
in you know closer to la and have some
other people live there and it would be
like the second the second hype house
but hootie once he got into that new
house he's just like not making content
for the high pass he just doesn't want
he just doesn't want it
yeah
that makes sense sometimes you outgrow
the hype house
yeah until all the time the people that
we were left with like aren't that
famous and oh they're sticking around
for a reason
do you remember when i went on this
whole journey with you explaining to you
these two tick talkers who were dating
sienna may and jack no i only remember
nessa
okay well i did explain it to you they
were like this really cute couple
what's that from
i've no idea wicked
um
they were this like really cute couple
who one day like broke up and then they
were both like accusing each other of
sexual assault it was so crazy
and they like lived in the house are
part of high pass and they were cut from
the show like literally i saw sienna at
they did this like fake wedding i'm like
oh my g like when you think of the
timeline like they were together they
were in the house i'm sure they filmed
so much because they were like two the
most popular but they're so toxic that
they were completely cut out of the show
damn
so it was just really interesting if
you're like an 11 year old wannabe like
myself
and i did really enjoy it except towards
the end i was like the show has gone on
for too long because nothing actually
happened okay okay so it doesn't sound
like i'm gonna watch it but you know
what i did i saw it and i i thought it
was interesting
yeah and when i first started me and ben
were like this is really good like it
was really good it's so interesting to
see how like their business works and so
there's this company called bang energy
which is like i know it as a tick tock
brand it's like people are always like
sipping on it and they're like sponsored
videos so they sponsor the entire hype
house and they pay for the house and i
think in order for that brand deal to
continue they have to do like i think
they said four or eight videos a month
on the high pass instagram with the bang
energy and no one does it like if you
like none of the kids want to work on
the hype house so i felt annoyed for
thomas that he's like running this brand
these kids are living in the house and
nobody wants to do anything for him
but he was also like not really
acknowledging like all the kids that he
surrounds himself with like they lift
him up too 100 and it sounds like thomas
and i remember thomas from back in the
day and so he's
been around this whole time it sounds
like like he's not really people aren't
really interested in him but he like
understands that like you know if we get
all these people together together we're
interesting but like he's kind of just
like expl not exploiting because i don't
know what practice yes he uses but he's
just like
using them and then he's upset when it
doesn't work out but it's like your
intentions probably are shitty too
no and then like his girlfriend was on
the show and like she was like a main
character even though she's relatively
unknown and she's just like his biggest
defender in the house and it just like
didn't come off well because
well yes i understand your frustration
thomas that like you are running this
business and no one's helping you like
you're also not really talking about how
you're literally like using everyone
else too like everyone's using you and
you're using them right right so it was
a really interesting dynamic i don't
know if i would recommend it definitely
not for you and i don't i wouldn't say
like definitely watch it but if you're
interested in these types of things i
thought it was interesting and just like
content houses in general yeah no i'm
glad that you watched it and then you
gave a little recap i feel like i feel
good about it i can i can move on it's
not something you have to say like you
can miss it okay i was planning on it
but i i was like a little bit like
what's going on over at the hype house
so right now
um we do have an official tv recap at
the end of the show with real housewives
of salt lake city that was on last night
but before we dive in i have um two
major developments oh from over the
weekend okay okay
the first is that after you know much
demand i have decided to um
add a second show in houston so the
tickets just went on sale if you go to
dot com girl with no job.com tour you
can get those tickets in houston the
next day i'm doing a second show tickets
tickets tickets tickets ticket tickets
that's announcement one
but the second announcement is more
important okay i know what it is and
yeah i agree
so over the weekend first of all i had a
great weekend on friday night spritz
hosted a party to celebrate sophia la
court's birthday all the cool tick
tockers were there i felt so old but i
was like fangirling but were you all
were you so involved like that's so
exciting yeah it was like my dream yeah
no the party looked amazing so villa
court is like the human embodiment of
spritz
and it looked like so much fun
it was a great party i had so much fun
and my friend gabe was there now for
those who don't remember gabe
remember i would say maybe a month or
two ago i told you guys a story about
how i went out and i fell and it was
really really embarrassing and i was
like spending the whole weekend like
just really trying to remember figure
out the layout of the room who saw me
and my friend gabe who was right in
front of me swore that he didn't see me
fall so that really gave me a piece he
swore
i don't remember him swearing i just
remember swore i just remember you
asking him and he said no
but he would like said it so
emphatically he's like no he's promised
like you didn't fall okay i'm like okay
so and that really gave me like
reassurance because if he didn't see it
then who did right and i was convinced
everyone did but if he didn't he was the
closest to me so i don't know what
compelled me when i saw him on friday
night to bring it up and i was like you
know i really haven't been able to sleep
since the last time i saw you when i
fell because like i know you didn't see
it but i just really felt like everyone
in the room saw it and it's like my
greatest shame you brought it up to him
yes yes oh i thought he brought it up
no it's jackie it's so ingrained in me
like i when i saw him it was the first
thing i saw i thought of oh okay okay
okay sorry i'm slowing down my story
so i was like
i don't know what compelled me i was
like you really didn't see me fall and
he was like no i did
i was like excuse me he's again i want
to make you feel bad but like i totally
saw like you on the floor on your back
i'm like
what this changes everything now i like
i've been spiraling with with false
information and now i have to spiral
with correct information knowing most
likely everyone at the party saw me fall
you have to spiral even further because
you were spiraling with like you know on
a good day and everyone's like you have
no reason to worry gabe didn't see yeah
well he did yeah no i i don't think i
ever said you had no reason to worry
and i do appreciate the lie it was one
of those lies that was like meant to
protect me
but deep down like i knew you know yeah
no no i know and i actually think he
went about it the total right way
because it's like at the time i don't
think you could have handled the truth
like you would have spiraled you were
already spiraling and you were just like
questioning everything but now it's like
a few like i think that you've recovered
and now it's like you do need the
information like the truth always comes
to light
and the truth will set you free yeah i
thought he brought it up because his
friend's girlfriend heard you talking
about it oh wait yeah wait which is even
funnier
yes okay hold on wait yo no he did say
that maya
yeah listen to the toast podcast and
asked gabe like did you see claudia
fault he's like yeah of course yeah
which is even funnier
that he was just hard until he saw you
and he knew that you talked about it and
that his lie made it onto the show
yeah i mean
i don't really know where to go from
here that's the thing like
was it too long ago to continue
spiraling or does this new information
like force me to spiral no okay you need
to put it behind you for sure you have
not fallen since correct
correct i did stumble but i was just
with brian in the middle of the street
like no one saw okay that's fine the
streets the same shoes though the
streets are so [ __ ] it's not you it's
the it's these streets they were the
same shoes
that i fell in at the other party but i
love the shoes and i will not stop
wearing them okay that's a problem
because that would be like a real
takeaway like maybe i have to stop
wearing any shoes um
but if you haven't fallen since i think
like you just need to focus on not
falling going forward no i think that's
a really really good takeaway for sure
because you can change the past and all
we can do is learn from it
yeah
but just the shame like the sheer shame
like every now and then my mind will
just like
go to that moment and i want to die like
literally die caught in one way or
another we've all been there might not
be falling per se might be saying
something might be doing something
losery like but we have all been there
we've all lived with the shame and
it's a part of life i think it really
makes you stronger you know what oh my
god this book that i was reading
had the best quote at the beginning that
it really sums it
i just like was making a lot of progress
moving past it and now i'm like back at
square one
yeah no but this
this quote i love a good inspirational
quote do share okay i don't know if i
can get
i would have to go to my kindle to like
get the exact quote
but it's humility comes from humiliation
like i guess but i just feel like i
could get humility somewhere else i mean
this seems like a really fast track
you're so humiliating
i'm so
humble
you're so humble claude and that's the
important takeaway i just wanted to
share that major life update with
everyone who's been on this journey with
me i appreciate you and the second thing
i want the third thing i wanted to share
was that i got a message today jackie
from someone with the name brandolin i
saw
and she validated everything i said on
friday's episode she said i just
listened to friday's episode and i'm
brandon pronounced bran da lin and i
cringe cringe when people say brandy
lynn so the name does exist it wasn't on
the chalkboard but it does exist oh
but you were saying bran lynn
no i think i said brandon no you said
bradlin and then you said brandyline
no i think i said brandon lynn okay you
know what you're going through a lot i'm
gonna let you thank you just let it go
okay okay okay thank you it's gone
it's been gone well now that we're all
caught up are you ready to launch into
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
yes i am but before i do i have to let
you guys know that today's episode is
brought to you by turbo tax people think
unusual circumstances mean complicated
taxes but but for turbo tax live experts
that's what makes things interesting
life changes are exciting and they
usually have tax implications maybe
you're a full-time employee who decided
to freelance and now you
need some advice on how to file as a
contractor or maybe you started driving
ride chair after your 9 to 5 job or
maybe you work in a state but live in
another and you need help reporting your
income luckily turbotax has experienced
experts dedicated to answering all of
your tax questions and finding every
deduction for you
and you can talk to them from your phone
without ever having to leave your house
whether you got married had kids or
changed careers turbo tax live experts
are ready to help you with your unique
tax situation and get you the best
outcome
turbo tax live experts an interesting
life can mean an even greater refund
visit turbotax.com to learn more you do
your thing they've got your taxes intuit
turbotax live and today's episode is
also brought to you by relatively famous
there's a new show coming to e in
january it's called relatively famous
ranch rules and it's hilarious they took
eight kids who have celebrity parents
like the hoff's daughter shaq's kid
billy bob's thornton's son pat benatar's
daughter and a bunch of others even easy
daughters on the show anyway they
dropped them onto a ranch to help them
out for the summer and they're supposed
to you know save the ranch and these
kids come from super privileged
backgrounds and they have zero life
skills and the show is amazing besides
all the crazy ranch stuff they have to
endure like breeding cattle and chasing
pigs around they have to contend with
each other's rich kid drama because of
course they all think they're so special
the kids are totally unprepared for any
of this they've never even had to cook
for their own food before they've never
now they're being thrown into a
situation where they have to figure out
how to cope with real life and real work
for the first time in their lives it's a
lot for them as you can imagine the show
has everything bad behavior romance
bromance hookups and the occasional
cattle drive it's relatively famous
ranch rules and it starts this january
only on a
awesome thank you claudia
it's a pleasure
our first story um is news from last
night very sad news bob saget the star
full house in america's funniest home
videos has died at the age of 65. the
comedian was reportedly found dead in
his hotel room at the ritz carlton in
orlando on sunday afternoon following a
performance in jacksonville florida
saturday night tmz was the first to
break the news the orange county
sheriff's office confirmed saggett's
death on sunday after deputies were
called just after 4 pm
local time the man was identified as
robert saggett the sheriff's office said
and pronounced decease on the scene
detectives found no signs of foul play
or drug use in this case they tweeted
okay this is like one of those things it
reminds me of how i felt when i saw on
twitter
when tmz announced that kobe bryant had
passed away like you think it's a hoax
because it's just so impossible
you know i'm not an old person not a
sick person and i was just so in
disbelief
for a while until i really saw that the
orange county police department twitter
uh tweet that confirming that that it
happened it was just
really shocking and really really sad
and i feel like most people our age feel
very connected to bob saget whether or
not you've followed his work in the last
10 years we all grew up watching full
house danny tanner good morning san
francisco like it's just
he's really ingrained
in so many of our childhood memories
and this is so so sad so confusing
really shows you like life is so crazy
like you could just be here one day and
gone the next it's so short yeah it's so
short this news was shocking and i think
a lot of people were especially shocked
like based on his recent social media
posts like he was just having like the
time of his life performing and doing
stand-up and this and podcasting like he
had a whole new like gen rebirth of his
career yeah oh for sure and like
especially his stand-up career as of
recently and then all of the tributes
that have come out have really shown
like how many people he impacted both
you know his fans and fellow comedians
and how he really impacted the world of
comedy and
it's it's such upsetting news
you know i did this zoom um i think
almost a year ago now it's like to
celebrate purim
and it was like a bunch of jewish
comedians um like acting out the story
of purim and bob sagan was in it and it
was like such a big deal he's
so funny and he just went off script a
bunch of times and was just like it was
so cool and you see like every
every comedian who is now like sharing
tributes
sharing stories everyone says like the
nicest guy the most humble like the
genuinely funny guy and i think when it
comes to
comedians i think a lot of people always
think like the first thought is you know
there's so much like depression in
comedy and so many people
you know end up taking
the route of suicide um and when you
read these tributes from people you just
hear like how bob was just like full of
life and full of and how he like helped
other people through those moments like
pete davidson wrote something right
really sweet tribute to uh to bob about
so many of the times that he helped him
and pete's mom when pete was going
through it right so he was just like
this figure in the comedy community
and it's so
so sad yeah
truly
and i mean of course everyone like he's
65 years old which is not
not old not old he was you know happy
seemed to be healthy so i think a lot of
people are
questioning what happened
right no foul play no signs of drugs
like what happened what happened so i
mean obviously it will depend on his
family and what they're willing to share
but i i think a lot of people are very
confused by this yeah and he has a wife
and three kids so it's just it's really
really sad and this is just one of those
things that was like all night i just
couldn't stop thinking about it it's
just so shocking and so sad yeah
terrible
that's a big loss
yeah
well pivoting to our next story some
mindless celebrity news perfect
kyah gerber is newly dating austin
butler after her breakup with jacob
alordy now dudes i can't remember if
we've spoken about this
i don't think so okay so
kaya is dating elvis star austin butler
after her breakup with jacob lordy page
six can confirm a source said they're
newly dating kaya thinks austin is a
sweetheart they're having a lot of fun
getting to know each other so i just
feel like i have so many thoughts
overall cute cuteness wins
but i feel like there's just like this
circle of
models of people
actors etc who just like keep dating
each other so this was just like the
next spoke on the wheel for both of them
100
but i do really ship like i think this
is so cute i have an extremely
extremely soft spot in my heart for
austin mahone like i don't know why i
think it has a lot to do with the carrie
diaries like austin butler
[Laughter]
oh my god austin mahomes
he's like that that kid who was like
fake just dating camilla cabello yeah
yeah okay he just came up on my tick
tock like yesterday that's why i said
his name oh my that is so embarrassing
yeah truly truly
i really need to get off tick-tock okay
i have an extremely special spot in my
heart for austin butler i think he and i
think he's so cute and so handsome he
really touched my my soul in a really
unique way when he was in the carrie
diaries and i stand him and vanessa ann
for so long and i never thought i would
get to a place where i'd be happy for
him in a new relationship because to me
they were so otp but i actually really
like this and i think he has like
i wouldn't say he's like that famous
like he hasn't acted in that much but i
think this elvis thing this i think he's
about to be he's like a huge star yeah
it's supposed to be the thing but you
know what we've been talking about it
for a really long time now and it's
really not the time to become a movie
star unless your movie is going to
netflix and it's you know um
what's that available on demand like
yesterday yeah the kissing booth like i
don't know that like even if this movie
elvis like say got to the right streamer
and like everybody watched it
i don't know if it's it's not the same
as it was pre-coveted or back in the day
so i still think like it'll do really
well for him and he'll
but i just don't know if it's going to
pop off how it would have if
this were 2019. no by the way you're a
hundred percent right like there used to
be movies that would like remember how
we were all like quaking by um
slumdog millionaire like
every person in the world had seen and
there was like a movie like that a year
like being you know in the pictures
was the
biggest best thing and now i'm thinking
i'm like no like there are tv shows that
are so popular
launch like millions of careers to
millions of people it's like not a thing
anymore you're 100 right no and also all
of the shows that are coming out now
that are like the big ones so i'm
thinking of like 1883 specifically like
each episode is a movie literally
they're over an hour some of these
episodes like downton abbey some of the
episodes were an hour and a half so what
you did one hour and 45 minute movie and
we're supposed to care as much as a show
that has taken over our whole lives
right like the first thing that comes to
mind is euphoria even though i don't
watch it but
um the premiere was last night and like
people are just [ __ ] quaking when you
think of all the people in the show like
yes it didn't launch zendaya zendaya
launched it but jacob lordy like well
that was huge for him sydney um sydney
sweeney
like it's just
tv is like it now yeah no the movie
industry like has
crashed not with a thud but with a
whimper and i think
it's no clearer than the fact that the
golden globes were on last night not
we're on they weren't on well they
weren't they happened somewhere and the
the winners were announced somewhere and
they're in the news but like nobody
cares
yeah no it's wild and i think it's
i don't even think it's a generational
thing because it used to be like
the way that i see it
it's like only kids watch tv you know
but now it's like really motion picture
quality
[ __ ] is happening on streaming services
with tv shows no it used to be like not
just kids watch tv but like there was
you know the movie stars and tv stars
and like being on the small screen was
just like you're you're always going to
try and be a movie star and it's just
not going to happen but you could have a
lot of like commercial success and make
a lot of money so that's that's pretty
sweet but now it's like i would rather
be in queen's gambit than than a
a two-hour movie
no and i think that's like so evident
with zendaya like zendaya is in my
opinion probably one of the most sought
after actresses of our time right now
and
five years ago if someone was in
zendaya's position they would not be
doing television shows but euphoria is
like one of her most popular
gigs yeah
i don't know why i keep bringing
euphoria but it's a good example yeah
considering you don't watch never seen
it but i have been um like slightly
like into it just because everyone's
trying you should watch it i feel like
you would like it and it would connect
you to the younger generation to the
youth yeah i just feel like it's a type
of show that would give me anxiety you
know yeah i
i think i tried to watch the first
episode once and it was just not it was
not for me
and then that's not to say it's not a
good show because people love it no no
and i and not to say that it wasn't a
good show i was not for me yeah there
are plenty of things that are not good
shows that are for me and plenty of
things that are good shows that are not
for me mm-hmm
speaking of uh great shows though um
snitch just let me know that there's
like a rumor floating around that
victoria's season four is not going to
happen because of kovid and
i just i need to i'm going to try
something i'm going to manifest
oh yes you should season
repeat after me repeat after me okay i
don't chase
i don't chase i attract i attract
what is mine what is mine will find me
will find me that just seems like really
self-centered for like a show that
probably costs like millions of dollars
to put on they can afford it and like
you know the whole
no people love it and you know what
they will figure it out in a safe way
they absolutely have to it's an
incredible
incredible show and actually
into our next story
which is kate middleton's nod to royal
history the duchess of cambridge's regal
black and white 40th birthday photo
shoot channeled classic portraits of the
queen princess margaret and the queen
mother so k middleton is turning
her 40th birthday was yesterday and
kensington palace i realized it was for
her 40th she looks great yeah they
released three portraits revealing sides
of the duchess of cambridge rarely seen
by the public the pictures were taken by
italian fashion photographer paulo
reversi in kew gardens she is wearing
alexander mcqueen's excuse me she took
these in queens
that's so true i didn't realize she's
k-e-w k-e-w gardens
so she took the train to flushing for
these photos one thousand percent
i'm sure and cultural icon the photos
are very reminiscent of you know some
earlier photos of the royal family which
is really interesting it actually made
me think a lot because i feel like for
centuries all the royal portraits look
the same because they were you know
painted or you know done with like not
high definition photography but now like
it would be weird to have like pic
actual the pictures that they take like
hanging around the palace next to like
gilded photos you know painted by
michelangelo no they have to maintain
like a similar aesthetic yes so and i
think they did a really good job on that
front because this picture like reminds
me of like the pictures i googled queen
victoria yes i think the art direction
is really like on point i just didn't
like love i think like i just didn't
think the photos highlighted her beauty
yeah you know what i mean like they
weren't that flattering and she's like
the most gorgeous woman in the world
it's like not hard yeah i would agree
with you but i mean i'm sure she had
complete editorial approval i'm sure
they took a million photos and these
were the ones that she liked
so
so that's fine they're not bad by any
means but for to me she's like this
great beauty and it shouldn't be you
know hard to find the right light at
lighten angle for her and i just didn't
feel like these were her best shots i
hear that but i also think that like the
look like the glam and the dresses are
very timeless whereas a lot of times we
see her and she looks very much like the
2020 woman you know she's that's true
she has the beachy waves she's swearing
self-portrait you know but i think that
these photos really blend well into the
context of royal family portraits
classic timeless i agree right anyway
it's cool to like see
always but like the main one that's
being sent around like with her shoulder
in front like i literally didn't know
who that was
is that the black and white one yes but
no she's wearing the red dress oh yeah
yeah
that's not the one i've been seeing the
most i've been seeing this black and
white one the most but yeah we'll share
them on our instagram um they're
beautiful i'm not trying to be a hater
at all i just i was like surprised yeah
but it's always funny like what
like you could take a picture and be
like you look sickening and you're like
i look disgusting i like this one i'm
like i would never choose that for you a
hundred percent like the way you they
wait and i feel like this is true for
like most people the way you see
yourself and the way that others see you
like two totally different journeys yeah
yeah
so this was pretty cool i feel like it's
been a while since we've gotten some
some iconic queenie [ __ ]
i feel like the last time we saw like
iconic photos was like harry and megan's
wedding and like they were all together
in the living room yeah and i mean like
the
[Music]
kate and william put out like their
family portraits at christmas and
everything but like those aren't the
sort of things that go get hung up
around the palace because they're very
modern modern they just got framed on
queen's desk and they go to like
instagram for kensington palace 100 i
think i officially just followed their
instagram
i have to say after these photos dropped
the marketing team over at kensington
and like all the different palace
instagrams is pretty pretty good yeah i
followed the royal family their official
account and i think i did i i think i
might have pressed the follow on this
one after like you know being there so
many times at kensington royal at
kensington royal yeah that's the or is
it duke and duchess of cambridge
i think it's kensington royal
there's so many
so many but you can find the pictures on
our instagram don't worry thanks
are you ready for our next story i am
but i have to do today's sponsor because
it is a sponsor that literally got me
through last week i've never drank as
much liquid iv as i did last week i just
i got a package with two new flavors and
it was just everything i needed that's
why i was in like such a good positive
mood last week so the new year is here
and there's no better better way to kick
off 2022 than by making sure you're
feeling like your best self um whatever
goal you set for yourself this year for
me it's definitely staying more hydrated
drinking more water making that a
priority
and i'm going to be doing that with the
help of my favorite hydration drink
liquid iv so one stick of liquid iv in
16 ounces of water hydrates faster and
more efficiently than water alone it's
super easy open up a bottle of water put
it in your hydro flask
it's a packet pour the powder and shake
it up it makes it taste so good and it's
filled with essential vitamins like b3
b5 b6 b12 vitamin c and it has three
times the electrolytes of traditional
sports drinks so i of course like to
drink it throughout the day but also
after you know a long evening of
cocktailing around the town a liquid iv
can change lives
and it's so effective because of the
cellular transport technology so it's
literally designed to enhance rapid
absorption of water and other key
ingredients directly into the
bloodstream they're also on a mission to
change the world they have donated over
19 million servings globally so when
you're purchasing from liquid ivy you're
saving yourself from a lot of trouble
but you're also helping out to change
the world so you can grab liquid iv in
bulk nationwide at costco or you can get
25 off when you go to liquidity.com and
use the code toast that's 25 off
anything you order when you use the
promo code toast at liquidiv.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidive.com promo code toast wonderful
now our next story is chaotic chaos from
our chaotic queen claire crawley
new man
claire crowley is cozying up to a new
man who is also a former contestant on
her season of the bachelorette blake
monar she says this is what her soul
needed
so
this is like a trend right now where the
leads are going back into the pile of
discards for sloppy seconds and choosing
anew and i just it makes a lot of sense
but it also
is confusing that like
someone would go for that you know what
i mean right because in one way or
another it's just kind of like going
back to your ex but wouldn't you be kind
of butt hurt if like someone didn't pick
you and then like it didn't work out
with the person they thought was better
than you so they come back like crying
to you yeah but like this is even
crazier i can understand like like
that's like an ari lauren situation i
can understand like in the height of the
moment you make the wrong choice
basically of course and and that's
different than this which is like i
think i don't even recognize this guy
and we watched your season so like he
must have went home like week one two or
three like she didn't even
like never give him a chance got to like
any sort of level with him didn't look
it twice at him so that's like more
surprising
yeah because like what comes to mind is
like when peter after you know trying to
date everyone finally ended up with um
kelly
and like for me that wasn't like
offensive because i do think like at the
end of the day they were the most well
suited for each other and even when they
were when we were watching the show i
was like really surprised she went home
at number four
but yes like kind of picking someone
random
from
a pile of discarded men does seem weird
to me
yeah and that he would go for it because
like if someone sent me home
night one i there's just nothing more
offensive
no like you didn't think i was more like
beautiful enough you didn't think i was
interesting enough you didn't think i
was like nothing about me stood out to
you didn't like my dress you didn't like
the way that i spoke you didn't like my
little you know gift at the beginning
like yeah you didn't like anything about
me i don't know when this guy did go
home though it was it had to have been
early because we would recognize him and
he would have been like around for tasha
and stuff that's true i'm like it's just
blake monar when did he go home
i don't know
but i'm happy for claire that she is you
know in a new relationship
and i just i wonder why this is this
seems to be happening more now like
obviously katie thurston is dating
someone from her season that she didn't
choose in the end um but it never really
used to happen
maybe it's like social media
yeah because they get to like keep in
contact yeah
i don't know or maybe like people are
really just keep making the wrong like
maybe the show production has just
gotten so off the rails that it's not
conducive to people making good choices
he was eliminated on week two okay
that's night one
very very sad i can't say like if that
were me i definitely am too you know
egotistical i would be so [ __ ]
butthurt i would not
but blake is a better man than us yeah
and maybe i hope that they're meant to
be i really hope that they get married
um
and then it's all good all i want is a
happy ending for claire yeah
me too do you think dale is crying
no what is dale up to
they
collectively were the most toxic couple
i think to ever come out of bachelor
franchise
um and i don't know what he's up to
living his best life i hope so
best wishes best wishes are you ready
for our fifth and final story
no
yes
i've been like botching them from home
i'm like nervous yes maybe like close
your eyes pretend you're in the studio
okay
it's the final story
[Music]
okay hold on hold on yeah i bought [ __ ]
i missed it okay here's the thing i i
stopped singing with you because i
thought there was a delay in our
recording but it's a delay to you
let's try it no it's not it's not it's
not no
listen let's try and sing it together
put the mic put the triangle down
no
three two one
it's the finest no it's not working no
it's working for me okay three two one
it's the final story
[Music]
justice for blake best of luck with
claire
i have to listen to that how we did it
because for me it sounded like janky as
hell no for me it sounded right but it
felt like your arm was moving too slow
no it wasn't see like that's just the
technology don't doubt my rhythm [ __ ]
technology can't keep up with our
musical inclinations and we're gonna
it's just like crazy you know we can
send a man to the moon but we can't sing
the final story together remotely it's
disgusting disgusting but our fifth and
final story which will lead into our tv
recap which was that mary cosby bailed
on the real housewives of salt lake city
reunion which likely means she is not
returning for season three
that is so disappointing i hate
when people don't show up to reunions
like it's so
unfulfilling so sources are saying that
she didn't attend the reunion and
sources being page six because she
confirmed it no no yes everyone knows
she wasn't there but there's they're
speculating as to why and they're scared
that she was scared they said that she's
scared of being grilled over her season
two controversies the source said um she
was terrified of getting grilled about
her racist comments made towards jenny
and jen she also did not want to discuss
the accusations that she runs a cult
right like she was walking into like a
true
lion's den because she's not been held
even remotely accountable on the show
for the atrocious things she said and
honestly like meredith who was like
really like a a favorite of mine like
she's really just digging herself into a
grave with mary it's so weird and now
like mary left her high and dry at the
reunion but then also like there is so
much coming out on the internet about
mary and not even stuff that they've
addressed on the show like more stuff
about the church
i don't really read it i can't get into
it because it's like so complicated but
there's like a lot
about the church
yes and just like mishandlings
misappropriating money uh
you know manipulating people like bad
[ __ ]
got it i mean
i don't know i found this to be
surprising even though like she has a
lot to answer for at the reunion if you
if i had to guess like who wasn't
showing up i wouldn't have guessed her i
feel like she's constantly like
she doesn't care enough about anything
to not show up right and this like
really solidifies the fact that she
won't be on the next season which like
really doesn't bother me that much she's
kind of irrelevant to the storyline
she's like very much like a funny
character and has like funny moments but
a lot of times she also like takes away
from whatever is going on um so i don't
think it's like a major loss but i did
find this surprising because even
throughout the season like especially
with the church stuff every time it
comes up like she'll go there and try
and
explain herself and i feel like last
season at the reunion they did bring it
up and she explained like how she has
all of this wealth and all of these
things
so
i don't know i i expected more from her
and i honestly a part of me feels like
i saw like a funny tweet that like her
assistant like forgot to tell her
it was reunion day no totally she's so
messy like that totally could have
happened right no i'm disappointed in
the sense like we're investing all this
time in the season which by the way i'll
get into the recap is not good oh my god
sorry i said it it's not [ __ ] good oh
my god i'm in shock over
last night's episode
right and so we're putting all of this
time into it and we're not and the
reunion is where we get our questions
answered and the fact that we're not
gonna get that from mary even though so
much of the discourse is about mary it's
really frustrating as a viewer it's just
like i feel let down and i'm like
[ __ ] annoyed honestly
yeah i i don't know i don't feel as
annoyed about like the merry stuff it
seems based on what
we're seeing on the show of like
cars uh that guy's name was carson right
cameron cameron sorry cameron says this
i've heard that mary says this it all
seems very like personal you know he
said she said yeah he said she said like
this is how i experienced it this is my
truth and it's hard there's not a lot of
like concrete facts
so i just find myself like you know
wishy-washy on the whole thing and and
without the facts and without you know
if she is running like a a fraudulent
cult
then there should be some sort of you
know prosecution or something and
there's nothing like that so it's like
no right like whitney is not the fbi
right but but by the way the fbi is
coming for someone on your show and
we're going to be your best friend but
we're but we're going to continue to
talk about how mary might think that she
is god like that's moronic it's moronic
so
it's disappointing that she didn't show
up to the reunion i'm i don't really
need more discussion about the church
stuff because there is nothing
concrete
yeah um and just to be honest we'll dive
into like a full tv recap but like my
general takeaway from all of this is
like
you know these women were kind of gifted
this once in a lifetime opportunity to
be a part of an iconic historic
storyline on housewives and i just think
at the end of the day like they're not
experienced enough to handle it they
only have one season under their belts
they don't know how to navigate
something like this and they are [ __ ]
it up so dreadfully like i was doing
everything in my power last night to not
squirrel tick tock like it was
impossible when they went to commercial
breaks i was like think the [ __ ]
heavens i can go on tick-tock it was so
bad and i don't know if i'm the only one
who feels this way but like i am
inclined to stop watching like i am
started to dread the episodes i am
inclined to stop watching the
conversation that took place on the bus
first of all in general they have
completely fumbled the ball on this gen
shot thing like jen shaw gets arrested
by the feds homeland security and nypd
and it turns into a referendum on mary's
job not just that makes no [ __ ] sense
to me let's one thing at a time ladies
one thing at a time but sure
[Music]
the conversation on the bus
was the most illogical thing i have ever
heard in my life like
i this idea that like when jen said in
her testimonial who hires a private
investigator unless you're hiding stuff
too
what not true what are you talking like
what are you talking about also meredith
has said repeatedly i hired a pride
investigator to investigate these text
messages that led me to jen i didn't
hire a private investigator on jen
herself like oh and jen stole from
meredith's store
it's so crazy and then
jen is like sitting there saying to lisa
you'll stand by someone who would hire a
private investigator who would dig up
dirt on people you're going to be
friends with someone like that that's a
reflection on you okay if that's by that
logic if i'm friends with jen shaw um
and she has brought in old people
hundreds of old people over the last
like many years is that a reflection on
me because i would hope that it's not i
would hope that you would argue against
that sort of logic that like we can be
friends and you can be going through
something or doing something that
potentially i don't agree with but i can
be there to support you she's like
completely like but no one will even
call her on it and the fact that
everyone's just like sitting on the bus
like
and and having to like bad-mouth
meredith and it's like if meredith's
guilty of anything it's just like not
doing enough
right like she she's done nothing
controversial really
except her friendship with um
with mary
but like
it's crazy how the level of conversation
like the heightened level of
conversation when it's like
it's so bizarre to me and the fact that
they're on the bus and they're all like
harking back to the last time we were on
the bus it's like funny jen got you know
arrested by the feds
right no it's not funny it's not funny
it's it's so crazy she's just
getting off scot-free
it's crazy well like
i guess we're diving into the tv recap
is that correct oh yeah we've been here
okay we've been here well the tv recap
is brought to you by curology a
game-changing custom skincare made for
you by a dermatology provider they'll
create a custom prescription cream for
your specific goals whether that's
tackling acne clogged pores skin texture
dark spots fine lines or something else
you start by taking a short online quiz
and uploading photos and if it's a good
fit they'll ship you your formula right
to your door it even has your name on it
so i've actually actually just got an
email my shipment of curology is on its
way i've been like now through two
cycles i always focus on skin texture
because i struggle with dry skin
especially in the winter but whatever
you're wanting to tackle whether it's
like acne fine lines breakouts
curology will
take care of it also i loved doing their
online quiz it was pretty in-depth so
like you send pictures of your face
they're really making sure they're not
just giving you
uh
generic
because like we all have different skin
why should we all be using the same
skincare we shouldn't it makes no sense
so get started with curology just like
we did and you get a three a free 30-day
trial at curology.com toast just pay
five dollars for shipping and handling
when you go to curology
c-u-c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash toast to start your free
30-day trial cancel anytime prescription
subject to consultation curology spelled
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com toast check it out your skin
will be very grateful
yes so
can i tell you what really bothered me
about the episode sure
everyone like quaking being so confused
as like there's something more going on
that meredith doesn't want to be friends
with jen really like how we could all
sit back and watch what jen did and said
to marry this child like you don't [ __ ]
with someone's child of course meredith
would never want to be friends with jen
and now all this information is coming
out about jen potentially being like the
most horrible person on the planet why
the [ __ ] would meredith want to be
friends with her and why does that
confuse everyone like why are heather
and whitney like sitting around stewing
like what else could it be nothing no no
no there has to be something bigger than
a federal indictment into jen that would
make meredith not want to be her friend
after a whole year of her still not
wanting to be her friend and based on
everything that meredith has seen from
jen i would conclude that meredith
believes that the feds have their facts
straight it's just of course like right
like if you believe that jen did those
things you wouldn't
want to be her friend i'm going to
assume that the ladies who are standing
by her um don't think that she did it
which is how they can you know
be there to be her friend otherwise like
how could you be friends with someone
who would do like such evil things like
that but it's also within meredith's
right to say no i think that
you might have done that
like lisa barlow was on to something
whitney and heather bad weather they
really are having the worst second
season of all time like equal with liam
mcsweeney like she had a really bad
second season they are so on the wrong
side of history everything that comes
out of their mouth is so stupid and i
just want to say that whole boob cake
thing was really inappropriate but it
was also really inappropriate of like
everything seth says about whitney's
boobs like good on whitney for like
making a joke out of it but like if that
were me like i literally slit my
husband's throat yeah no that was you
know
every relationship is different and i
just can't ima like if my husband said
that once we would go home and i'd be
like and you never say that again but
it's clearly just never leaving this
house ever again
it's literally just like a running joke
within the group i'm glad that like
meredith and uh whitney are fine with it
but i think most people would not be
um i think the person who was really
it's so hard everybody is having a bad
season probably you know
shockingly jen's isn't even in the worst
shockingly completely shocking
but someone who's really really up there
is heather especially considering she
was such an mvp the first season and
even last night she said like she was
right about some something that she was
wrong about and she was like and i was
right and i'm always right i'm like no
you're [ __ ] not no she is literally
stinking it up everything that comes out
of her mouth is like stupid and wrong
and i loved her and i just don't know
what's going on and i think that it's
like this thing that happens when you
have an amazing first season like
everyone loves you you think like you
could say and do whatever you want we've
seen it happen a million times and i
find it more interesting when like a
housewife has a really bad first season
like to read like i literally never
hated someone so much in my life than to
read and eileen davidson like two of the
woodiest votes ever and they both have
come out as some of my favorite
housewives of all time so starting
strong is like the worst thing because
you just get this like ego i think where
everyone loves you they're turning
everything you say into like memes and
you think that you like you just can't
get arrested when like everything you're
saying sucks no and it's like you if you
have a great first season you're really
like on the right side of a lot of the
arguments and like you're just really
this like
force for the voice of the audience then
you just assume that like everything
that you think is correct and what and
what people want to hear and then you
also go even harder because you have a
little bit of encouragement and you
don't see yourself just because you were
right in the past about like 10 out of
10 things doesn't mean you're going to
be right about the 11th too no 100 so
it's just like
it's hard for me to like find any sort
of
interest in my soul for this show
because i don't i can't stand by a
single woman like i can't say like i
would be on her side i agree with her a
wholeheartedly 100
i agree
completely all so messy and they all are
so [ __ ] over the place like the fact
that whitney and heather especially
whitney like heather has always been
like spineless loser desperate friend
for jen but the fact that whitney who
was like going so hard on the bus and in
bail has now done a complete 180 and is
like so up jen's butt it's so confusing
like they all stand for nothing
it's so confusing i'm so i'm trying to
think of like who do i agree with most
probably meredith
but not even
yeah or honestly maybe lisa i know i
agree
but she's like when she's wrong she's so
wrong and she digs her heels in like so
hard and yells and she definitely is
like an annoying person to hang out with
like just a very loud very all the time
yeah yeah and they aren't
they are trying to do like a thing with
the husbands like making it very new
jersey house so i was like seth had a
confessional i personally like it i love
all of the husbands and it can't be
worse than the wives no and they're
getting like they're actually friends
and they have funny conversations i'm
here for it if you're in a city where it
works out
i personally love to see it there are
certain husbands i really like i love
whitney's husband like love okay and is
it just i tried to tell you this but you
didn't um
you didn't see it but maybe you see it
now he looks like hannah brown
what like google pictures of each of
them they look like i think they're
related
jackie what the [ __ ] are you talking
about claudia you know i mean
what john justin oh just
whitney rose husband
yeah
okay you only need to look at a picture
of him to see it
oh just came up who is justin rose when
he rose's husband sued for running a
pyramid scheme
um
okay i'm like not seeing it you're not
it's a picture i actually like am hold
on
i gotta make a side-by-side collage yeah
and you know believe it we'll put on the
instagram and we'll we'll let people
sound off and let us know if you see
what i'm seeing
he's so cute i really really like him
um and then
john lisa's husband like gives me
absolutely nothing i don't like him i
don't dislike him he's just like boring
and quiet
i'm like kind of over seth
said this a lot
yeah he's like he thinks it's about him
and it's like it's not i like him still
though
but but he's a lot but also like he's
like the joe gorga of the group like he
yes you know is a lot but he's gonna get
everyone together and doing crazy stuff
i would have loved to have seen robert
senior golfing with the guys but that's
just like never gonna happen yeah
maybe that would be the thing to like
bring mary in because it's like as much
as whitney and lisa [ __ ] hate each
other i've never seen two people who
like literally
get under each other's skin just by
breathing more like their husbands
really get along and like it's not even
yes they have to like stay tethered to
each other because of the show but also
like that element makes it to like okay
i have to like
be a little more patient with you
yeah and like the sharif of it all i
used to really respect him
because he was like this man of like
honor you know like football like
and i guess i mean i don't expect him to
turn on his wife but just like buying
into her lies and delusion i'm like i
thought you were like a you know an
honorable man yeah and i just want to
say one thing that i saw um when they
were doing their couples therapy um
paintings paintings and then like she
jen showed hers and then sharif showed
his i just want to say that both of the
paintings had the same um handwriting
on them
so i'm pretty sure what are you
suggesting i'm just suggesting that um i
don't know if jen did both or like one
of the assistants did both and it was
just like completely [ __ ] fake
but they were the exact same handwriting
and they were painting so it's like
that's really hard to do yeah
so very very interesting yeah just
something that stood out to me
i really appreciate that it's a very
detailed note you took
and then it's like what so what the [ __ ]
am i watching this i don't want to watch
couples therapy
no couple therapy there were so many
skippable scenes that being like the one
that comes to mind first
um and the party was just like weird
it's like daytime but everyone was
wearing like evening gowns yeah and no
dancer in the pool like and then
everyone jumping in the pool oh my god
when heather almost fell like i swear to
god i felt that in my belly like i felt
so much shame for her like i related to
that wholeheartedly like if she had gone
down any further and like actually hit
the floor she would have had my deepest
sympathies yeah it's really it's
shocking like this franchise had
everything going for them they had an
amazing first season and then they had
this
major national story
and
it's become one of my least favorite
i mean it's so hard because they're all
so bad it's become really hard to watch
when i was so excited about this season
100
so that's what i'm saying
um
yeah so
we'll keep watching but i can't i can't
confirm how much longer i'll go for
no i will go till we have to see this
thing through but um
it's
it's really disappointing i expected so
much more
and i think like jenny
sucks
yeah i would agree
she's hanging on to the show by thread
and that thread is named carlin
100 and even when they're like all
fighting on the bus and she's like it's
just
it's i can't explain
how and why this everything is so
illogical but it just is no i feel that
you know and and me trying to see like
logic in understanding what's backwards
about it is driving me insane
i'm literally still laughing that you
think whitney's husband looks like
it's so funny i you don't understand i
told you this weeks ago and i think you
wrote back like huh you didn't even look
into it
i'm gonna make a collage like i love a
collage and that's the only way i can
really see like side by side people
he really looks like her maybe they are
related
i don't think so you never know
you do never know that's a good call
so let us know you guys will let us know
what you think about my call i usually
have some pretty good calls and they're
really they're really out there
but when i see when i know when i see it
like i see it
when you know you know
all right well that is our show you guys
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast milani morning show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast and where
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcast find us
the morning toast and leave a 5 star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing monday rise and grind and we'll
see you tomorrow rise and grind you guys
so important
bye